thousands on the Streets of London the
second of four days of climate protests
the message familiar but this time the
tactics have shifted
it's less about disrupting the public
and more about asking them to join in
campaigners like Chris Packham an
important New Direction I mean no one
here is being arrested no one's sticking
themselves to anything no one's throwing
any soup I hope everybody's soup with
them to be positive but you know we're
asking people to step up at this time to
move one rung up of their comfort zone
into activism
those attending the protests from groups
like Extinction rebellion and others
agree previous methods may have been
counterproductive Extinction Rebellion
Hears A lot
support your a
ID that we need to change the way we do
things so that everybody can be part of
this movement disruption causes
resistance and we need to unfreeze the
resistance and get people to think
rather than just argue there was
an air of nervousness
uh due to their previous tactics
um that have been a bit you didn't want
to get arrested no and you know you want
to be
safe and feel that the people that
you're bringing with you are safe
although the intention appears to be for
a peaceful and orderly Gathering events
May get in the way
on Sunday hundreds of thousands of
people are due to come to Central London
to either take part in or watch the
marathon now we are told that there is
no intention to disrupt that event but
the concern is there will just be too
many people in too small an area
whatever happens these protesters say
they will keep demanding change in the
weeks and months ahead
simmering Under The Cordial atmosphere
here is a deep fear of the future and
growing contempt for politicians their
own internal reports are showing their
woefully off track so uh yeah we're
definitely not going to meet those
Targets in fact we're heading in the
opposite direction so yeah don't believe
it at all leaders need to lead and
they're lying about the types of actions
that they can take to mitigate climate
change they're not doing enough they're
not stopping fossil fuels and that's
what we need to do
that seems unlikely ministers are
expanding oil and gas drilling rather
than shutting it down putting them even
further at odds with a movement that is
increasingly determined to be heard
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News in
Westminster